thoughts are with christian wood  and his badly rolled ankle  yes he got fouled on that play so he was  lining up to shoot free throws so he  could maybe stay in the game but you can  see he's  his teammates are telling him finally  somebody's helping him walk because he  is in a lot of pain and that thing  we got to look at it in the timeout it's  already really swollen  yeah there you go take some pressure off  that he  he's not going to be able to return here  tonight that is a bad ankle sprain and  he is in  a lot of pain and frustration too  because he wants to play but there is  just some times when  you just can't do it  so the grizzlies select rhodion kuruz to  take the  foul shots here is is wood is wheeled  back towards the rockets locker and all  the best of christian wood  and did you see vic victor oladipo went  back there with him that's a good  teammate to go back  on a serious injury like that to go back  and and just give him some moral support